[Musique]
on a envie de faire quelque chose avec
vous on a envie de faire
le danse avec jack lang c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année on a remarqué que le casting
de danse avec les stars étaient un petit
peu faiblard donc venez au centre les
chroniqueurs vont vous rejoindre à
chaque fois vous allez entendre notre
nom les chroniqueurs vous allez voir et
vous avez dansé sur les différents
styles de musique vous suit vous vous
danser pour qu'as-tu jack lang et sa
partenaire
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
ça tangue
[Musique]
se rajoutent endiablé jack lang et son
partenaire gilles verdez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va tu perdes mais lui faut le calmer
jack lang et sa partenaire enora malagré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une salsa jack lang et sa partenaire
ballerini
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la revue
sur une cheville jack lang et tous les
chroniqueurs et de tpm p
voilà donc à claudia jack ada tout ça je
pense je pense que ça restera dans les
annales de la télévision française
[Musique]